this program was recorded in december of
1986.
there's a
figure i read the other day 900 billion
dollars in arms traded around the world
each day
i mean each year
1.7 million a minute or something like
incredible figure might as well be a day
900 billion a year
now
that means that there are planes and
ships going each day every hourly in
every direction everywhere in the world
there's arms going here to be shipped
there undoubtedly if you looked hard
enough you'd find u.s arms going to the
soviet union and soviet arms going to
england and all over the place literally
it's a gigantic business it's one of the
largest businesses in the world with
every kind of a deal you can imagine
iran has been getting arms what what
they needed from all kinds of suppliers
including israel of course and now it
comes out the u.s being involved now
more than any other presidency perhaps
ever he's just been blowing off the laws
and running operations all over the
world
and now a couple of them have come back
to haunt him do you believe the story
that meats told
isn't even a little bit plausible uh
it's not in the nature of government
bureaucracy
uh
in bureaucracy you have meetings and
authority and you go to the boss and the
boss writes your fitness report and
people cut your orders and they approve
where you're going to go and cables are
sent ahead to set it up for you to meet
with people and
the approvals especially on money are
endless there isn't even the slightest
possibility that he was doing these
things uh just totally independent they
weren't you know coming and going from
the white house for god's sake with
nobody knowing what he's doing the
illegal ones
and i imagine there's illegalities and
most of them the way their style of
management is
the illegal ones they're going to start
perspiring heavily
and literally you're going to have
people who had jobs like mine
before that are going to be going into
the boss's office and when he gives you
orders we'll have out a spiral notebook
and be writing down in front of him what
he said with a date on it
showing him that you're writing it down
and things like taking other people in
the office with you
former c i a official john stockwell
analyzes the iran reagan situation
and speculates on what's happening
behind the scenes tonight on alternative
views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this program was recorded shortly after
the contract revelations began
and a lot more information subsequently
was uncovered but compare this
presentation by john stockwell with what
you were being fed by the establishment
media and the politicians
we're very pleased to have with us today
and alternative views author and peace
activist john stockwell who served with
the cia for 13 years quit the agency
wrote a book exposing the angola
operation that he directed and since
then he's been a major critic of the cia
and u.s foreign policy we have john in
our studio the day after the revelations
of the iran contra connection and are
very eager to discuss this momentous
event with john so welcome to
alternative views john what was your
response to the revelations that the
money from the iran arms sales went to
fund the countries were you shocked
surprised how did you feel about this
i felt vindicated i was a little bit
surprised at the utter stupidity of mr
reagan's cabinet and conduct
self-destructing is what they're doing
but we knew
that they were delivering arms to the
conscious illegally and we've just been
waiting for a break something to happen
some incident that would bring us some
hard details so we could get our teeth
into it and this happened
it happened over his dealings with iran
which brought out the contra connection
but john isn't this really i mean the
media are making this out to seem like
it's something very special but isn't
this just the usual covert action that
has suddenly come to the surface and we
can see the operations of work under
it's especially under mr reagan who's
been blowing off all the laws and just
just free wheeling through space he's
had this great sense of his own
popularity as being above the law as
being untouchable
and that the people will love him and
support him no matter what he what he
does
more than any other presidency perhaps
ever he's just been blowing off the laws
and running operations all over the
world
and now a couple of them have come back
to haunt him the one the iran arms sale
what's so poignant about that is he made
such an issue out of uh anti-terrorist
activities of bombing libya that he
would never deal with terrorists and
this is a very important element of the
the conservative ideology is you don't
make any deals no matter in the malta
incident you know they stormed the plane
and 50 some odd people were killed most
of them by the team the swat team that
was storming but you never cut a deal
with the terrorists and here he cut a
deal with the terrorists and it's
murkier than appears because of the
the ci station chief bill buckley who
was uh
who was one of the hostages and that got
him involved in trying to track it down
how does this now you've been involved
course in the past in covert actions and
of course you ran the angolan operations
how does this differ
in
procuring of arms and delivering to
where you want them to go and
laundering the money through swiss banks
etc is this a pretty much typical
operation
there's a
figure i read the other day 900 billion
dollars in arms traded around the world
each day
i mean each year
1.7 million a minute or something like
incredible figure might as well be a day
900 billion a year
now
that means that there are planes and
ships going each day every hourly in
every direction everywhere in the world
there's arms going here to be shipped
there undoubtedly if you looked hard
enough you'd find us arms going to the
soviet union and soviet arms going to
england and all over the place literally
it's a gigantic business it's one of the
largest businesses in the world with
every kind of a deal you can imagine
iran has been getting arms what what
they needed from all kinds of suppliers
including israel of course and now it
comes out the u.s being involved now
what's what's happening here with the
reagan administration is it's it's
illustrated by the difference in colonel
oliver north's position and my own
because i had the same effectively the
same job in the angolan opera flying
overseas and setting up deals with
israel to trade for
missiles and whatnot and hiring
mercenaries uh very much comparable
except
then we we broke the law but we were
still playing it within the structure of
the national security complex and the
congress oversight and the cia
as it's set up to function however
unfortunate it may be that's the way the
law has it structured we briefed them
according to the hughes ryan amendments
we were required to do on the angolan
operation we submitted a finding saying
we were going to do it and then we gave
them briefings but a lot of that was
lies right we lied the hughes ryan
amendment does not you know prescribe
that you have to tell them the truth you
just have to briefly oh my god and uh
i mean it's presumed you know it is a
felony to lie to him and we did lie to
him but at least we were working within
the structure my office was in the cia
headquarters
now we we sat at 177 meetings of a
subcommittee of the national security
council
and then every couple of weeks a meeting
of the national security council to
supervise this thing and other things
under the reagan administration it's
oliver north is working from the
basement of the white house
with another marine colonel bob
mcfarlane and the admiral poindexter
and uh this is where they have
self-destructed
as they've gotten outside the process
they didn't even bother to tell the
congress which the law requires them to
do and they're running operations all
over the world the laundering of money
is certainly very much part of the i
mean the ci's budget is depending on who
you believe is between for the ci covert
operations itself 3.5 billion to 4.5
billion and that's a lot of money some
of that's for buildings and things but a
lot of that is 100 million here and 400
million there
all over the world lots of activities so
the banking system is very important
here i was reading a story about there's
a bank in baltimore
where there was a whistleblower a guy
said hey we're doing all this stuff for
the cia we're doing all this illegal
stuff and so he called uh his bosses and
said hey we can't do this and so they
fired him but it was all it was kind of
like ci but ci has banks all over the
world well they don't really own banks
that that's cumbersome necessary
they work through banks a lot of zurich
they have a full-time finance office to
handle all the financial transactions
the beirut station before i doubt if it
still pertains now
but before used to be a big ci hub of
financial
see the ci's making payoffs often in
local currency and and it can't be
traced so you have to buy large sums of
money of every currency in the world and
then be able to deliver it back to the
country and hand out you know a million
dollars or 500 or whatever in
untraceable money and this means you're
laundering money all over the world
banks all over the world hong kong is a
big place for john let's let's focus now
on oliver north and his particular
funneling money to the contras would he
have to have had cia connections to be
able to carry out such an operation
could someone operating out of the white
house basement do this alone do you
believe the story that meats told
isn't even a little bit plausible uh
it's not in the nature of government
bureaucracy
in bureaucracy you have meetings and
authority and you go to the boss and the
boss writes your fitness report and
people cut your orders and they approve
where you're going to go and cables are
sent ahead to set it up for you to meet
with people and
the approvals especially on money are
endless there isn't even the slightest
possibility that he was doing these
things uh just totally independent they
weren't you know coming and going from
the white house for god's sake with
nobody knowing what he's doing with all
of the liabilities all of the games
politicians play
and you know all of the concerns they
have about getting re-elected and having
their constituents win
not even the slightest possibility that
he was even and as a matter of fact
niece is admitting that there are others
involved what they're trying to do is
damage control right
they've thrown oliver north to the
wolves and the question there
is have they cut a deal with him
are they counting on him to go to jail
for him if necessary if someone has to
go to jail is he going to play gordon
liddy and out of loyalty to the chief go
to jail
poindexter now he's hedging and saying
he knew some of what's going on can you
imagine a navy admiral who just wouldn't
bother to know what's going on when
you're dealing with iran and hostages
and contra wars and things like that and
big congressional debates
uh
colonel bob mcfarland was i mean he flew
to iran with the arms he was you know he
was obviously involved in the
discussions with whoever the israeli
individuals were who actually put the
money in the swiss account for the
contras
uh what they're trying to do is shield
mr reagan
now if you've been reading the news at
all
oliver north and macfarlane getting to
see him spend more time with him than
some of his cabinet members because they
can tell real sea stories that you know
during the old cowboy on about invading
you know patrol here
a big raid into turkey and things and he
likes the adventure and the excitement
and you know they're close to the guy
my sense of it is that reagan is gonna
there's there's the teflon is coming off
in patches and he's gonna lose some skin
off his nose
but
probably the congress will ho draw back
from
from putting themselves in a position
of forcing out the questions after which
they would have to impeach him
i think that they were probably
essentially after making pay a hell of a
price they'll let reagan off the hook
eventually and what about the cia to me
this has all the earmarks of a william
casey covert operation as you know as
you reported on the show many times
casey thinks the covert operations are
the alpha omega of foreign policy so it
seems somewhat unlikely that he would
not be involved in this and what do you
see of the cia role in all of this
they've admitted there were some cia
operatives you were talking earlier
about bank laundering wouldn't there had
to have been a cia bank
account or some sort of setup to make
approval yeah the office of finance
believe it or not there are enough
bureaucratic controls in there that even
the director of the cia
can't take 30 million dollars and throw
in some bank account somewhere without
having some form you know to go through
as i read it the money
but to finance this operation to buy the
arms here and fly them to iran with ci
money and then in effect iran paid for
some of them and that was written off i
mean you write off this money
now the details of this will come out in
the in the investigations but you buy
the arms in flight and that's a project
and you write off this money then the
iranians paid for the arms and they took
that 30 million dollars and put it in
the bank accounts
now it was cia money so the charges that
this was being run solely through
the national security council
which in itself is a misnomer the
council or the cabinet members but the
office in the basement of the white
house
it doesn't really track if the ci put up
the money you had staff studies projects
forms filled out the finance office is
getting approvals and everything
and then the profits and the returns
there had to have been
between 10 and 300 cables
going back and forth to set all this up
this very complicated operation that
went on the negotiations for years
if the congress in its investigations
tries to really get into the subject and
get the file subpoena the files
they'll find cables from the ci with ci
directory you know going over saying
this proving that and set it all up a
lot of double talk in the cables but
it's all it's all integrated
casey
self-destructed a little bit in 1984
when he ordered the the mining of the
libyan harbors
oh i just came from a long interview and
then a lunch meeting uh the mining of
the nicaraguan harbors
uh you know in which he was blowing up
our ships
and that was when barry goldwater you
know turned on him and
and patrick moynihan and the congress in
the senate and they shut him down
and uh nicaragua shut the cia down in
nicaragua and this was a big loss of
face
for the cia and it curtailed a lot of
their activity
they still you know are doing angola and
afghanistan and a libya chad operation
and an ethiopian operation and a
campaign operation but still
some loss of face for him and i'm sure
casey
uh in fact didn't he tell us didn't he
have the press conferences in 84 and
angrily say we'll find other ways to
work through other countries to do this
and some of the people in the congress
said that would be illegal but in fact
they they weren't able to to force it
you know
but now we're going to see that this is
a manifestation of what he promised to
do and what he did we have seen this
before
in the cia and the us using other
countries as surrogates for instance
we've seen them using morocco to try to
circumvent their restrictions against
the being involved in libya in angola
they would use the moroccans to
transship equipment to
uh the angolans and the rebels and they
also would train train some of those
people from angola up there in morocco
we've seen them use
argentina and of course this brings us
to the israeli connection most people
don't realize what a close tight
relationship the u.s has not only with
uh israel in this regard but also with
israeli secret
[Music]
mossad police you tell us about the
israeli connection well it's it's
intimate uh
uh compatibility of objectives and
purposes and close liaison
uh it's a little bit one-sided and that
the israelis don't play it straight with
anyone
they uh they they have the sentiment
relationship with the cia and they get
lots of things from the cia but they
don't necessarily tell the ci the truth
about what they're doing
in many
cases some of this is documented in
i believe it was the mark's marketing
book and then in the church hearings in
1975
they documented that 80 million dollars
had been spent by the cia through israel
to run covert activities in africa
that's fairly substantial it's not it's
not a lot of money in terms of a
cultural war but for routine covert
actions that's a that's a lot of money
well we know that the israelis supply
arms to countries like guatemala
and also
i think i read where they also give some
to the countries as well and a lot of
other authoritarian and brutal
governments around the world chile
argentina yeah now is this done purely
to
support their own armaments and to
provide them with foreign exchange or
are they uh
middlemen once again in a lot of this
with the cia you suppose all of the the
above and an infinitely complicated
you know world of activities israel
tries to buy a lot of friends
they get arms from us and they trade
them off to other people and they
produce some of their own
and they can go into
what is usually
non-progressive governments fastest
governments
and uh make a deal and and deliver arms
and you know establish a relationship
through the arms
of production and in the united states
clearly is in this case and
and the contras and others
uh where for various reasons we don't
want to be upfront in the thing work
through israel and it looked in this
case like they wanted to get arms to the
contras through any means earlier we'd
reported how saudi arabia in exchange
for the aywax had sent a lot of arms to
the contras and evidently israel too as
part of a deal with the u.s had funneled
the money to buy the arms to go to the
coaches let's focus on this the sending
of arms of the contras now we saw how
the american flyer hasn't fuse was shot
down on one of the arms delivery uh
excursions was this a sort of typical
mode of delivering arms that has also
the mark of the cia upon it
yeah the reagan's denials of this one
are implausible
uh there's not the slightest possibility
that the reagan administration was not
behind the haas and fish thing as a
matter of fact someone told me that on
the mcneil lira show last night uh they
brought out the fact that there were
phone calls from hussein fuss himself to
the white house to oliver north yeah who
had been in charge of uh supplying the
contrast was also in charge of bombing
that mining that harbor outside of um
he's been the coordinator of this thing
just as i was for angola and this
telephone call from
from hussein fuss to north these coals
apparently i mean that's documentary
evidence what we've got is in july and
august there were articles in the la
times and newsweek senator kerry
investigating senator berg investigating
saying that the ci had already delivered
in the past two years when they weren't
supposed to
about 150 million dollars to the contras
and they're supposed to be investigating
this already
well we have this 30 million dollars
and the 15 million dollars that came
from saudi arabia apparently so that's
45 million so we've got 105 million
dollars more to track down and this is
all illegal the bowling amendment was
passed that specifically
uh forbid
second arms the bolland amendment has
been superseded but uh in 1984
intelligence bill
uh
prohibited uh aid to the contras except
for that humanitarian aid right and it
prohibited the ci from managing the
thing so it's definitely illegal wasn't
that the reason they moved into the
white house say if we're the cia is
prohibited from doing this we'll just
take away from the cia quote unquote and
put it in the white house well the
prohibition is broader than the cia
though the prohibition would cover the
white house and colonel north and shut
off the money now this information has
been talked about it's been common
knowledge and even in the regular media
they had they've had stories about it
but nothing
was ever made of it until the iran
situation that's right and how do you
account for this why suddenly is there
so much media attention and so much
criticism of the reagan administration
they've been lying for years we know
that carrying out illegal covert
operations for years and then suddenly
this just explodes
well you could answer that at different
levels depending on the bent of your
mind if you're into howard zinn's
philosophies
or charles higgins
of the united states being controlled by
the fraternity of financiers
then they would theorize that the the
financial establishment that owns the
united states effectively has decided to
dump reagan
and the reason would it would probably
be that he is self-destructing and he's
no longer serving their interests
adequately
you know who knows if it really works
that way and if they really got together
and said okay let's dump him it could be
just purely in the dynamic of the thing
because there have been a series of
things there was a haasenfuss the libyan
disinformation thing the great debacle
in iceland right and now breaking his
own
ultimate code of dealing with the
terrorists buying them off delivering
arms to the people who took our embassy
hostage now even though he's trying to
say that that the people that we were
dealing with in iran the iranian
government were not the ones actually
killing our hostages
in lebanon
uh it's nevertheless the same government
that took or you know worked with the
students who took the embassy hostage uh
and that mr reagan made so much noise
under jimmy carter he cannot wiggle you
know off of that well this sequence of
things and his last one being so
well
the next to last one the iran
ransom
so contradictory of his own ideology and
then this thing of of money to the
contras in defiance of the law
i think that you know whether or not
there are three billionaires who plan
all of this
uh i think there's a factor working here
of great and mounting frustration
at the man's teflon
the the media for all the fact we've
lamented the fact that the new york
times and the washington post have
refused to hold him vengefully
accountable through the past six years
for his
his mental errors and his illegal
activities uh they nevertheless gave it
a little bit of a shot and it sort of
didn't sell the washington post in 1981
was calling him the great pre-barricade
or headline
and they could have oh yes i didn't i
didn't originate euphemism for liar yeah
the great the great liar
the headline you know the great
preparator and uh and
and even like grenada they put the truth
out and it just sort of didn't sell
and so they kind of you know threw up
their hands and sort of said we're stuck
with him a phenomenon where he just
doesn't have to follow the rules of
everyone else
but this has been frustrating for a lot
of people everybody except buchanan and
patrick have been frustrated by this
and even george will has been turning on
the man recently oh yes indeed he wrote
an editorial last spring saying that the
democrats were going to win this time
around
now it didn't mean he had become a
conservative he just felt like reagan
was betraying their whole agenda he was
losing it my goodness and breakfast over
in the white house oh i'm sure yeah i'm
sure he's had his last uh special
imitation can we talk about this
information that was one of the big
things that came there's a whole series
of these things that happen all the time
and it was rather interesting that the
administration admitted
or somebody blew the whistle on him that
they had
actually had a disinformation program
about libya over the past few months
quote unquote well anybody who's been
watching alternative views know they've
had a disinformation program not only
about libya for years but about just
about everything else that's been
involved
but this is a curious thing that this
would emerge too and the way the media
handles they said oh my goodness you
mean they've been doing so that's
terrible
whereas they could have reported these
things the disinformation and marvin
kolb
resigning
in shock you know uh
he had been part of this thing
and as a journalist and then as a
government employee
had never known about this information
and never seen it happen before he could
not possibly be that blind
i mean it it which is to bring us back
to the point of why are they turning on
reagan
the libyan disinformation thing was
totally apparent
to everybody who was watching the scene
at the time
uh and then someone gave bob woodward
the memo and uh which which proved it
and he used that to talk to people and
build and
and people talk to him
well let's talk let's just take off some
of these things that we've noticed in
the past as far as this information
uh well the libyan hit squads is a good
thing that was about fabrication now
that was they said that that was that
information was provided to him by the
israelis eventually that's what they
said yeah
and how about the uh
uh kgb assassination attempt on the pope
yeah
that that was something that blew up in
their face clara sterling is still
floating that one there was an op-ed
piece in the new york times a couple
days ago you think that would have been
laid to rest long ago
yeah they still br they still bring this
stuff out i saw she's saying that
although
saying oh you know they tried to
assassinate the pope it's been years
after it's proved to be pure baltimore
yeah despite the fact that the court you
know exonerated the bulgarians all
together yeah in italy claire sterling
is saying well they just you know they
just they had all the evidence they just
didn't feel like it was enough to take
action on there was the situation with
yellow rain this supposedly german
warfare is being carried out by the
vietnamese and the soviets in southeast
asia it turned out it was just b feces
the feces got real big by the time it
hit the united states you know but they
kept playing these things up like kal
007 that would probably be as
momentous as any we've done a whole show
on that it's been revealed even seymour
hirsch's book that indicates the whole
thing was a mistake does point out the
disinformation came out of the white
house and the state department from the
very beginning of that
episode
concerning grenada there were stories
for ages and that the grenada was
building uh submarine uh pens and
harbors for the soviet subs to use and
the and the machete gangs training in
grenada you know what was that well that
was with the submarine bases they the
machete gangs that did their terrorism
by chopping people up oh then you go
down to grenada and there are these u.s
medical tiny little islands these u.s
medical students walking around all over
the rioting there's scooters around
everywhere all over that runway that was
supposed to be for soviet bombers
of course the whole thing on nicaragua
has just been a complete misinformation
in my campaign from start to finish
and there's one thing i wanted to ask
you about
in a library journal i saw a very
strange well mike jankowski gave us
this article and said the cia for some
time
has been on a disinformation campaign in
that it
inserts into the u.s press and certain
specialized journals
misinformation about united states
corporations and technology and economic
development so they'll try to throw off
the foreign competitors is there
something new or the cia been involved
in this in the past i never it doesn't
surprise me there are no rules in the
you know in the game they play but uh
i've i've never seen that in the past
the economic disinformation by the ci
except
in a sense not to throw off foreign
competitors but of course
there was a great ci manipulation
that uh put mr reagan into office that
you know george
bush when he was director
set up a recooking of the ci statistics
about soviet arms
industry
and he was cooking it to make it to
create a myth of soviet military
supremacy that he could use to launch
himself into the white house and it
turned out mr reagan took it away from
him
and used it to get himself into the
white house but that was a flagrant
cooking of the statistics
there have been those statistics coming
out of the cia for some time trying to
indicate this
that the
russians have outspent the united states
and all but the
bases for which they use they're
uh are absolutely false to start out
with
well and and so much as in the
presentation they basically cook the
figures to make it look like or to show
if you will that the soviet union is
spending uh double the percentage that
we are on arms but our gnp is twice as
big so it winds up even by their own
figures to be the same amount and it
causes the truth more resources to build
a similar amount of arms so those
figures are completely misleading
especially in the last six years under
reagan although god knows it went on
under previous presidents democratic and
republican there's been a tendency just
to sort of uh cheat on on figures and
and double and subtract when they should
add and why not to make it all come out
to their interest well we've also seen
instances where
the analysts who are trying to do a
good realistic job and the cia they'll
send reports up to their bigwigs and the
pigwigs don't like the they figure so
they'll send them back send them back
that's happened with what um well a
specific example was uh
wild bill casey in 1982 ordered the ddi
the information directorate of the ci to
come up with a report summarizing a
situation in africa and they wrote a
very thoughtful report of
focusing mostly on the
indigenous problems it's obviously a
very troubled continent although most
parts of the world are nowadays but the
indigenous problems and dynamics that
are causing it to be such a complicated
and
volatile situation mr casey tore it up
and he fired that analyst
and or and hired someone else to write a
report that would focus on soviet
aggression in africa john you've been
talking about these various
disinformation campaigns and the various
cia covert operations for years
particularly throughout the reagan
administration you're given lectures all
over the country giving this information
out and criticizing reagan foreign
policy do you feel vindicated in terms
of the revelations in recent days that
even network television is now pointing
out that the reagan administration has
been breaking laws lying engaging in
disinformation what is your field
feeling about
uh your own work and trying to suppress
my my grin
feces eating grin is that what you're
saying
yeah 1981 i started uh noting in my
lectures
uh
reagan's deception
and dishonesty in 1982 and then
especially 1983 i began including the
rap on his defective mind
and uh i've worked on that many
different ways there's so much
evidence that you can work on with that
you know that you could go on a whole
night just about all of his
mental errors uh
jim right yesterday the congressman gave
an amazing statement to the press when
he was doing his press conference that
reagan just seems to be able to
completely neglect
facts and elements of reality that he
doesn't want to look at
and well there are two things working
one is the dishonesty the great
prevaricator
and the other is the defective mind
the other is when even when he's trying
he gets it screwed up
that's right that was clear in that
press conference on iran uh just this
week where he got all the facts wrong
and within 20 minutes of the end of his
press conference
they had to put out denial after denial
you know the man's record the man had
and it's not just senility the man has
all his life had this problem uh
15 years ago he gave a speech
about third world problems and nine
times in the speech he said third world
war problems
and you know just something in his in
his in his mind not connecting in one of
his first early impassioned defenses
of the sdi
the space wars thing uh he he kept
referring to it as a
a weapon a weapon system and his whole
defense is built on the point that it's
not a weapon it's a peaceful shield
now when i say when i make the rap
that he has a defective mind uh this is
not a cheap shot he is he is in fact the
greatest politician in our history if
you measure
his results at least up until last week
now we don't know if he's got staying
power but so far
uh incredible popularity and
persuasiveness and effectiveness
but it's like you know a fabulous racing
machine that has a cylinder too that
just you know cuts out and doesn't fire
correctly you've been on the show
several times and have given reports
that outside of washington many reports
have come out that an invasion has been
planned of nicaragua do you think that
these recent revelations make it more
unlikely
that this will happen how do you think
that thing in the paper today
um
saying that it's going to be a cool day
in hell before he gets before any mon
more money goes to the contras that that
you know it gives you a little bit of
hope if if they are sufficiently
incensed
and they're going to be going after him
with a passion
to investigate the details of this
violation of the law and delivering
money to the conscious this means that
they're not going to unblock the money
for more money while they're doing the
investigation and it's going to be
awfully hard for him to pull some end
runs and pull off an invasion of
nicaragua now
how
how badly he's hurt
and how much it will curtail his
adventures in the next two years
we just have to see
mostly
the united states people and washington
have the attention span of sort of a
long bolt of lightning
and uh you know and you have a crash and
a big fad lasts a few weeks and then
they go on to the next fed uh there are
exceptions and of course the vietnam war
stuck around a long time watergate stuck
around for two years until it brought
the president down
and uh we'll have to see will the media
the establishment
the congress will they
do an investigation and
you know they fired two people
will they accept that and allow him to
patch it back together or are they going
to really press this thing and really
clip his wing we've been talking about
nicaragua you made a trip there about uh
what five weeks ago or so for five weeks
can you tell us what you saw down there
you've been there several times and yeah
i believe i've been there eight times
altogether uh trying to get down short
visits though i still have a feeling of
not knowing enough about the country two
weeks here and ten days there which is
not
just cannot ever be profound uh you
gotta look around and talk to people and
get some briefings and uh try to do your
best to see
into and through and uh
i would summarize and this was my second
best trip today i came away feeling
pretty good uh
basically i would summarize it as saying
that there is there seems to be more
energy in nicaragua there was when i was
there than there was 18 months before
for example
and by that i mean
determination embattled confidence more
vehicles driving faster
the road in front of the
intercontinental hotel going up the hill
there
always has a lot of traffic but you
couldn't cross it sometimes for 15
minutes because of all the trucks and
cars and new toyotas and things
careening up and down
and uh
when i was there 18 months before it may
have been temporary with the country
that size
things can look a little dead and it's
just because another ship hasn't arrived
with petroleum you know and and it's
real tight and then two months later a
couple of ships come in and it uh
there's kind of a surge of you know we
have more and they loosen it up but uh
i i did not that what our media was kind
of trying to portray
reflecting reagan's leadership state
department views was that nicaragua was
getting close to the point where we
would be doing it a mercy to put it out
of its misery so to speak i mean this
was what they were sort of trying to
build up there was economic crisis
political repression etc and shortages
of everything and the people are really
suffering people really down
uh if if they're suffering and they are
uh it's true and there are shortages and
all of that's true but there's no apathy
nobody's sitting around uh the way you
see in the famine parts of ethiopia or
the sudan you know with their hands on
their head preparing to die that is a
very energetic country john do you have
a feel for what the multinational
corporations are doing there we've been
told in the past by economic experts
there are at least 200 multinational
corporations involved in doing business
and apparently doing well down there a
hundred of which are american
corporations is this still the case or
some of them pulling out
one thing i've never figured out in
international economics is when a
country really goes bankrupt you're
forever reading that i remember they
used to write it continuously about
upper volta
which is now burkina faso that it's
going bankrupt it is bankrupt but a
country never closes its doors like a
bank you know and and goes out of
business the people are still there and
the government's still there and trade
and commerce still go on
uh two years ago i was really depressed
because nicaragua's
debt was 4
billion and they seemed to be really
concerned about it and i asked them
about it again when i got briefed on
economics and what's the debt 5 billion
and they didn't seem to be upset about
it and well what's going to happen you
know who knows nobody can pay their
debts the united states can't reverse
the deficits the united states can't pay
its own debt can't pay its own debts and
mexico and brazil and argentina and
venezuela all have bigger debts and
they're not paying theirs either and
even david rockefeller says that
nobody's going to pay the debt yes
nobody can pay the debts
uh it has not shut them off from credit
now mind you they're hurting i don't
want to minimize their problems
but
they are still getting credits and
they're still getting uh gasoline and
essentials and food and whatnot i got uh
bitten by a spider and had a big
ulcerated infection on my back and so it
got me into the medical system
and uh in managua
i there were there are pharmacies all
over town and i had no problem finding
the antibiotics the doctor prescribed
just like that that doesn't mean that
throughout the country you can easily
find an antibiotic you need of course
john what do you think the impact on the
countries of these revelations about the
illegal funding of them and the
uproaring congress is this going to shut
the countries down will they be able to
get funding from other sources what
impact do you think it will have
i would say you know you know the the
the calling i got on the radio show this
morning that i was telling you about
where they were saying it's
the jubilance now is sour grapes from
people who lost the election in 84 and
my answer was
uh mr reagan is self-destructing you
know that's uh
whether you love him or not you're
either desperate if you love him or
jubilant if you don't but uh not sour
grapes
in in 1980 when when
it was announced that he had won there
was dancing in the streets in el
salvador and in the rich parts of el
salvador and this has got to have
exactly the reverse effect in el
salvador and especially in the countries
they have to be right now
already disorganized already corrupt
what you're going to have right now in
the last week
is contra commanders who had been sort
of thinking about well should i take
that five million dollars for my own you
know or should i maybe they'll come and
investigate maybe i better not they're
going to be going and grabbing what they
can take the money and run
you don't think they'll try some
desperate invasion or some well i don't
think they're out of business no this
has not put them out of business but it
means that the congress is not going to
be releasing funds
it means that the process the flow of
the thing right now
is going to be shut down marginal and
illegal things are probably going to be
stopped well didn't you say before that
instead of just 100 million which
congress authorized that through other
various accounts and shifting of money
that they come up with almost a billion
yeah there's a hundred million which is
cover for uh the larger uh the cia
according to the the what's what the
senator's investigating our reporting uh
has allocated 400 million from its
contingency reserve funds
and then mr reagan took 300 million that
had been allocated for famine relief
in ethiopia so that's 800. give to the
conscience well the 300 million would be
used in the region to create sympathy
i.e to bribe off the honduran generals
and the el salvadorian generals and to
do what they can in bribing costa rica
uh to create you know an atmosphere of
support you notice that the the
hondurans have just sort of once every
three weeks they balk a little bit about
are using them
and in el salvador they they're claiming
they weren't going to let us use the
lupungo thing uh the camp you know to
fly the haciendus kind of planes of arms
uh of course they're doing it but by
bulking every time they balk it's
another 10 million dollars gets empty oh
yeah oh yeah well do you think these
under the cover things these various
transactions will cease as a result of
it
they're they're pretty arrogant but when
you get into a watergate kind of a
situation people start covering
themselves and getting their heads down
and i would imagine that uh
the the the huge surge of contractivity
that that began i mean it was going on
but it began when reagan won the house
and senate vote this summer for contra
aid
uh and then of course climaxed when he
signed the bill and i think it was in
september making it legal
that surge of activity is probably in
the last couple of weeks cut down to
about 10 percent of what it was
maybe 15 we cut way down people are
going to all of a sudden
hold off on that plane you know and some
of the boulder commanders are going to
be saying you know fly the bloody plane
but people are going to be going around
saying would you sign this sir
do you mind if i tape record that would
just say that again fly the flag
it's a major setback i don't think it
puts them out of business but it's
definitely got to be a great big bucket
of cold water on their morale and what
about cia covert operations in other
parts of the world is this going to put
a damper on them make mr casey and his
operatives more careful or do you think
they'll keep their rambo
the illegal ones
and i imagine there's illegalities in
most of them the way their style of
management is uh the illegal ones are
going to start uh perspiring heavily and
literally you're going to have people
who had jobs like mine
uh before that are going to be going
into the boss's office and when he gives
you orders we'll have out a spiral
notebook and be writing down in front of
him what he said with a date on it
showing him that you're writing it down
and things like taking other people in
the office with you so these revelations
are really healthy then in terms of
preserving democracy and legality and
preventing you betcha illegal
interventions but john since the all
this thing started have you been getting
calls from radio stations around the
country and for network or for tv
appearances yes ted koppel yet uh ted
koppel i have neither pursued nor uh
i would do it i guess if i had to but i
don't have a great deal of respect for
his uh
his i guess it's it's not his integrity
exactly but it's his his orientation he
set himself
in in the position of bullying people
who are speaking against administration
policies we've all seen him do that so
many times now that it's it's just his
interpretation
of how he should do his job and i i
cannot see
how i would ever do his show without
clashing
he might have been or he might not now
you've been on 60 minutes a few times
yeah and lots of others and i was uh
quoted a couple of times on the dan
donahue show the other day
and he's considering having me on
and i'm lecturing continuously yeah
speaking of phil koppel or ted koppel
last night on nightline they had
alexander haig and henry kissinger on
the first people to make a commentary
and both of them were so self-serving
and you could see kissinger going on
everywhere basically saying he was the
solution to this if you brought a
professional in
someone who can impose discipline on the
white house then
and he also said well they shouldn't be
breaking the law or going against
congress
and the way the media let him get away
with that this guy broke as many laws as
anyone well just the fact that couple
would put hague and kissinger on and
then brzezinski's and other ones being
trotted out you know the perpetrators of
previous crimes
uh they're not making any effort for
for balance now
not really
if they had if they had had hague and
kissinger and someone like myself i
don't have the international stature
that they do so they might consider that
a mismatch
although a couple of years ago
i called home i was traveling in europe
i called home and my mother said abc was
desperately trying to track me down and
i called and it was a couple show wanted
to have me debate kissinger and bill
colby the cia director
unfortunately i was that night in
budapest and abc didn't have a tv crew
they could get the budapest in time to
do the show or fly me somewhere isn't
that typical though the way they set it
up they'll have those two people the
administration spokespeople they'll have
one person lonely person out there and
then koppel will jump on top of him
yeah of course i'd like to see him try
to do it but that's the way they do with
with their guests well this is the
problem i've seen carl sagan who might
admire enormously pull his punches under
couple's wrath and there was a
presbyterian minister
who just cowed in front of him and uh
there's no need
i don't see any reason why you can't
stand up to him and say wait a minute
you know you invite me here to to debate
elliott abrams
why don't you let me debate him you know
is the state department paying your
salary why are you taking sides this is
unfair i protest and you can say these
things right and it had been
tremendously embarrassing for him
because no one ever does that that
presbyterian minister was a couple was
you know are you saying that our
policies are designed to create misery
and suffering in el salvador and the
minister said oh no i wouldn't say that
i mean what the hell are they designed
to do 50 60 000 people we've killed down
there that's exactly what he should have
said that's what
that's the point of the presbyterian
church's sanctuary program is that these
people are not fleeing economic
conditions they're fleeing brutality and
we are responsible for the brutality and
therefore we have a responsibility to
give them a haven that's that's the
purity of the position so why was he
afraid to say that to ted campbell but i
think the crisis this time is just so
immense that whoever they bring on
except for maybe hague and kissinger are
really strongly criticizing the reagan
administration in terms i've never seen
anything near this
before in fact this morning i saw on the
today show hodding carter who described
the reagan administration as a group of
rabid rats who were in a sinking ship
and desperately scratching each other
and biting each other and see the beauty
of that before the ship sunk the beauty
of that you should footnote is it was
hiding carter who who had to take all of
the heat during the iran hostage crisis
when mr reagan was gloating and
insulting carter so much so hotting
carter getting back and getting back a
little bit of the work i think this is
how a lot of this information comes out
this happened in the watergate hearing
when james mccord one of the watergate
burglars just to protect himself started
telling the stories and blowing the
whistle on everyone else and i think
you'll see this in the reagan
administration as one by one they get
implicated they're going to start
blowing the whistle on other people this
is something that we alluded to earlier
that interested me a lot having been in
there and made a decision to testify to
the congress to try to bring out the
truth uh to help justice to be done
uh this gets into the gordon liddy john
dean thing with liddy saying dean's a
traitor and you know for for answering
the questions for doing what the law
required him to do
uh liddy you know would never betray his
commander he would kill for him he would
never betray you know uh it's going to
be interesting and then the bobby baker
thing where he went to jail and took the
rap without implicating lbj
uh
will oliver north take the wrap probably
and go to jail and keep you know keep a
stiff upper lip he's immersed
or will um uh and will mcfarlane say yes
i was involved but you see
poindexter
you know i said well i i was a little
bit of it i didn't really know what was
going he was hedging him he was covering
himself
so maybe oliver north is loyal enough to
poindexter the north will say i did it
and go to jail if it comes to jail if
they go after schultz i wouldn't be
surprised if he blew some whistles
yeah schultz
i do not add marshalls very much his
role in the
libyan bombing
uh his attitude his fraudulent attitude
towards terrorism
uh
his
attitude towards war in the weinberger
debate
with schultz it's schultz saying we have
to be prepared to go to war and do the
right thing and weinberger's saying not
unless the nation wants it so and
schultz is the one who proposed the
preemptive strikes bill where he would
put together a list he would put
together a list
of tourists terrorist sympathizers
terrorist supporters and if your name
was on the list you would not be
permitted to go to court and have your
name taken off the list and if your name
was all americans oh yeah and if your
name's on the list he could kick in your
door and kill you with impunity and he
said yes innocent people will have to be
heard in the process so like i say i
don't see schultz as any great saint but
he is clearly out of step with his boss
and the reagan administration in the
white house but it might just be to save
his own skin
i don't think it's going to do that i
think there's a little bit of that maybe
maybe jumping ship but i think what
happens is is uh
not so much
disloyalty to reagan as as in fighting
with regan this is something that henry
kissinger set in motion when he was
undercutting the secretary of state
rogers
it was what
made al haig to resign was the fact that
william clark inside the white house was
cutting him out of foreign affairs
and hague resigned eventually and
schultz is obviously trying to dump as
much as he can on the white house staff
and make them look as bad as he possibly
can
now
the community is calling for his
resignation and
my sense it would be so damaging to
reagan if schultz is fired or resigned
that he's probably going to try to keep
schultz on at least for a while
it i it it'll be interesting to see if
he keeps him on for the two years or
just for a couple of months
well it's fun to watch anyway no it's
the most exciting time in our politics
since watergate
well john
i'm sure we'll have you back again
you're going back to nicaragua here
shortly don't you well over christmas i
have to decide what uh what i'm going to
do i would like to get down and have
another look i felt an urgency to do
that
thinking that we might invade by maybe
february and you know and launch the the
central american war
now that that looks less pressing
there's an enormous amount of work to do
and i'm in addition to the lectures and
a couple of books i'm trying to finish
i'm
finally literally yielding to pressure
from people who've been saying for years
that
it isn't enough for me to come in and
lecture i have to offer people something
to join and something to do
and so i've got dynamic people in a
number of cities who are and sharp
people attorneys and phds and activists
of all kind
and we're putting together you know lord
knows the world doesn't need another
organization
but we're nevertheless putting together
an organization that's going to try to
our basic thought is this if if lyndon
larousski can put card tables in every
airport in the nation
putting out sheer drivel
why can't we in the peace movement do
the same thing except we have the
intellectual high ground the moral high
ground the economic high ground in terms
of what the arms race is doing to the
economy of the world why can't we put
card tables and rationally sanely appeal
to people across the nation why does it
have to be a lunatic bunch to
communicate to that many people and the
answer is that we just you know nobody's
bothered to do it well maybe they can
also get involved with public access
television sure another another
educational system you bet
good well thank you for educating us
again today
that brings us to the end of another
alternative use thank you for joining us
we'd like to thank our camera person
kevin west audio person judy burton and
austin community television ac tv and a
special thanks to austin mayor frank
hooksey he declared november as
alternative views month in austin we
appreciate it very much
alternative views is a presentation of
the alternative information network po
box 7279
austin texas 78713
we got letters and phone calls from
people all over the country in response
to alternative views
if you would like to contact us with any
comments or requests please do there's
our address
you